welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
vos and star wars the clone wars
released a trailer for its return for a
final seventh season on Disney Plus and
if you haven't seen the other seasons of
these animated series how dare you who
cannot be a Star Wars fan without having
consumed every movie every episode
booking comic Canon and legends radio
drama galaxy's edge holiday special
built as a Lego set on the Bader selfie
at Disneyland if the media knows like in
your tweet and being Davey Looney
himself since I'm so excited for this
series to be returning after its abrupt
end in 2014 I'm gonna break down this
trailer frame by frame point out all the
details you might have missed to explain
for all tiers of Star Wars fans what
this storyline will be how it will
connect to the Star Wars canonical
timeline throughout the prequels rebels
other films and the Mandalorians more
learning in case I predict anything to
accurately in that ruins your life let's
get started soon the Galaxy will be
remade the Jedi Republic
little guy
okay the trailer opens with voice of
mall who returned in season four the
Clone Wars he started the criminal
shadow collective took over Mandalore
briefly but was defeated and taken by
Sidious when we last saw him
molls story was continued in the son of
Dathomir comic Sidious tortured him to
draw out malls mother Talzin who died at
the hand of Grievous to help Maul escape
after that Maul regrouped with the
shadow collective and his Death Watch
loyalists to retake Mandalore which is
where this season will pick up depicting
the siege of Mandalore now there have
actually been a few sieges of Mandalore
that have been mentioned this one will
be the Republic's siege of Mandalore led
by anti mall Death Watch leader Bo Catan
and Jedi ahsoka tano recently departed
from the Jedi Order her role in the
siege was actually partially covered in
her novel by ek Johnston in the
Mandalorian the character Mothe Gideon
also referred to a siege of Mandalore
Mandalorian Hunter din Jarrah has heard
the songs of the siege of Mandalore
when gunships outfitted with similar
ordinance laid waste to fields of
Mandalorian recruits in the night of a
thousand tears but the siege is a later
siege by the post Republic Empire a
siege we have not seen depicted yet and
that one the Imperial forces including
Mothe Gideon invade Mandalore after Bo
Catan has United Mandalorian clans
against the Empire which is where rebels
left off presumably that siege is how
Gideon got his hands on the dark saber
so to be clear Clone Wars season 7 will
show us the Republic pre Empire siege
which will coincide with Palpatine's old
at 66 yep we're gonna see how that Jedi
Master ker affected ahsoka and how she
escaped it
more on that later molls words here seem
to confirm that he knew about Sidious is
upcoming treachery but she did hint at
after his return in season 4 I have
missed so much the force feels
balance yes there is conflict the Clone
Wars oh yes so it began without me
so before Maul got severed and Phantom
Menace he must have known about SIDS
upcoming plot to tip the galaxy into war
so probably he also knew what the end
goal of that war was there's a shot of a
republic Venator closing in on Mandalore
it's trapezoidal hull wedging down in a
brain just like Vader's Devastator in
the opening shot of a new hope which
hints at the Republic's pending
transition into the Imperial Navy voco
town looks out over Mandalore which is
covered in smoke and ash as if after a
battle so I'm thinking this could be
after the siege and after order 66 when
the new Empire bravely actually left her
in charge of Mandalore before that all
got changed obi-wan and mace windu join
the 212th clone battalion and Commander
Cody against some battle droids some of
them appear to be collapsing due to
these weird electrical charges mace is
like look this setting looks kind of
like the fortress world of an axis from
the unfinished episodes of Clone Wars
maybe these droids are being shut down
remotely like we do know after mace died
sometime after this
Sidious gave the order to have the
separatist shut down all their droids
but maybe that shutdown has already
begun like in phases and that could be
how mace and the others detected that
this war is bony either way I think the
season will show us mostly events
leading up to Revenge of the Sith but
maybe also some events concurrent with
the film and maybe some others that take
place after the film and with a shot of
Rex among his 501st clone trooper
battalion we move on I sense a plot to
destroy the Jedi
great care we must take
why would anyone walk away from being a
Jedi we were trained to be keepers of
the peace
not soldiers okay in this section we
visit Obadiah now this is the
headquarters of the Pyke syndicate the
spice smuggling enterprise that has been
linked with Maul but remember they were
also the ones who took the ores and
Count Dooku to shoot down the Jedi
sifo-dyas that was the Jedi who worked
with Kamino to build the clones with
that control chip that made order 66
possible
so perhaps ahsoka is investigating this
whole cover-up and then we get this a
Jedi hallo conference where Mei says I
sense a plot to destroy the Jedi this is
a direct quote from his line in Revenge
of the Sith a sense of plot to destroy
the Jedi which you know it took it long
enough this meeting includes Yoda flow
kun ela security Adi Mundi and hey that
looks like a lot of there which would
make this kid her Padawan a caleb dume
who will one day grow up to be kanan
jarrus the hero of rebels so it looks
like this final-season will likely
include a lot of these bridges between
the two series like this next Maul
tortures a clone this is Jesse
perhaps Maul is scanning Jesse's mind
and discovering the brain ship and
that's how he discovers the details of
order 66 or maybe order 66 included
orders to take out Maul as well with
Sidious trying to close out all his
loose ends oh maybe now Maul is trying
to destroy that ship is in the force
ahsoka tano ride to speeder bike and
Khorasan following her own path after
her leaving the Jedi so ahsoka was
framed for a bombing at the Jedi Temple
and even after clear to the charges her
faith in the Jedi was so shattered that
she told him to shove it we also see
this new character now this woman and
her sister are the twins trace Martez
and brothel Martez whom ahsoka befriends
on course and after leaving the Jedi
ahsoka shakes poket ons hand probably
Bukit on recruiting ahsoka to join her
in the effort to retake Mandalore from
all behind us Sokka that looks like a
Mandalorian mural artwork but that's a
course on guard beside it so maybe this
is on course on ahsoka met poket on and
liked the Mandalorian embassy offices
and ahsoka says the line we were trained
to be keepers of the peace
not soldiers is a line mace windu said
and Attack of the Clones with keepers of
the Peace not soldiers yet you know you
all armored up as generals during the
Clone Wars so you know like pick a lane
before it continued if I happen to look
lighter and more animated my delivery it
might be because I'm no longer being
weighed down by a clunky awkward wallet
thanks to our good friends at the ridge
who sponsor this episode so the ridge
makes everyday goods at a standard that
you don't see every day they streamline
your life by turning the things the
iqari like backpacks chargers wallets
into tools for a better living their
flagship product the ridge while it was
launched on Kickstarter in 2013 now sits
in the front pockets of over half a
million men and women I thought it was
just it was terrible it was over stuff
it had just too many of those folded up
ticker tape style receipts that we're
out of those pharmacy printers like
arcade tickets well that's not my life
anymore this is their aluminum wallet in
the raw color they have other colors
including some very flashy Tiki designs
this one is it's just light it's strong
and as a cool industrial chic vibe the
ridge is a minimal front pocket wallet
that's designed to streamline what you
carry every day it's 30,000 five-star
reviews and is a better way to carry
your cash and cards there's a lifetime
warranty if you love it and free returns
if you don't it comes in titanium carbon
fiber aluminum in over a dozen different
styles of colors they also have great
backpacks and travel bags with RFID
blocking pockets and optional device
charging batteries get 10% off today
with free worldwide shipping in returns
by going to Ridge comm slash new rock
stars
that's Ridge comm slash new rock stars
and use the code new rock stars and find
the link in the video's description and
let us move on with the rest of the
trailer we clones
[Music]
have mixed feelings to war
without it we wouldn't exist
okay some good clone action in this
section is shot a Cody Rex Jesse and
then woohoo a shot of some fellas from
cologne for its ninety nine the reject
clones with different appearances but
also unique skill sets they were from
the unfinished bad batch arc so it looks
like season seven will pick up that
storyline this kind of looks like the
rescue mission to find echo from the
separatist base friends that are there
is the commander hunter notice the skull
in bloom Owens armor he fires an e5
blaster that battle droids use and the
big boy behind him that's wrecker I'm so
excited to see these guys in the season
now next there's this battle on the
bridge guys this is my Guiteau the bacon
clan strongholds these same bridge where
ki-adi-mundi will get gunned down by the
21st Nova Corps 66 this is also the
planets they were headed to in the
beginning of Jedi fall in order and
before we move on there's this shot that
I think is death Amir because I think
these wind creatures are the mythic
supernatural spirits the beliefs of the
Nightsisters this all sounds like
nonsense to you hey you have a whole
month to catch up on Disney Plus get
crackin moving on part of the plan
[Music]
yeah plan everything is about to change
okay a small continues his voiceover and
John Williams force theme plays over
Asuka
holding her head in shark now I'm
assuming that this is after her escape
from order 66
we know from rebels that Rex was able to
remove his brain ship before order 66
went out and he helped save ahsoka so
maybe now she's feeling that survivor's
guilt over all of her former friends in
the order getting wiped out and one of
her former friends doing the wiping out
and speaking of a devil let's talk about
Annie his hair is longer more consistent
with him Christensen's hair in ruins
assists and boy is he angry he
encounters Admiral trench that brilliant
separatist tactician from season two
technically the earliest episode
chronologically somehow trench survived
that battle but anakin is back to finish
the job we see Rex leading his offshoot
of the 501st battalion the 332nd company
they have all painted their helmets to
match a sokka's face as a sign of
loyalty to her after her departure from
the Jedi this was revealed in concept
art by Colonia that was going to be part
of the show before was canceled in 2014
it's a sweet gesture but you know it's
also kind of a weird way to show support
like look us all go we painted your face
on our faces and we couldn't read her
reaction is like gratitude but also kind
of like cool
okay this section shows us the Republic
siege of Mandalore molls Death Watch
loyalists are the ones in red and black
armor and once with horns they're
fighting against clone troopers maybe
some other side of the Death Watch
members led by Bo Catan and super
interesting shot here of Padme this
ain't right because Padme is visibly
pregnant here and chronologically Padme
doesn't discover and report to Anakin
her pregnancy until the opening minutes
of Revenge of the Sith so this must be
after that but notice what Padme is
wearing here this is the same outfit she
wore at the end of Revenge of the Sith
when she confronted Anakin on moussed
apart and she got force choked and she
died so I'm digging this is another
example of a scene that could be sent
during the events of Revenge of the Sith
maybe when Anakin was alone on loose to
par but before Padme met him there maybe
they could be inserting this final
loving moment between the two because
you know let's be honest Anakin and
Padme in the movie it was just a bit
well hard to swallow
[Music]
every choice made has led to this to me
this footage looks like it could be the
Battle of course on to that Open Revenge
of the Sith like notice that fighter
does a barrel roll just like Anakin did
in that awesome sequence we might see
the prelude to that battle when Grievous
kidnap Chancellor Palpatine from course
odds which would also be around the time
of Anakin and ahsoka Spinal moments
which we know was right before that
battle more shots of the Martez twins
one of them has an exoskeleton mech suit
that we saw her used in the celebration
panel footage and then angry anni
slashes through Admiral trench is super
tactical droid you can see trenches
emblem on the droids shoulder there
ahsoka comforts a fallen Clone Trooper
now this is the same Clone Trooper who
appears to be dead on the floor of the
Mandalorian throne room the wide shot
with Maul so I assume Maul killed this
guy and now they're gonna do what house
ahsoka lights up to blue sabers and mul
is back in dual wield guys previously on
Clone Wars he just had half as
dual-wield since you know but we want to
split it and Phantom Menace later on in
the timeline and rebels small has a
makeshift dual wield that he customized
from an Inquisitor saber but this is
closer to his original dual wield but
notice how only the right half has his
original Mitter tip the west side is new
some are saying he could have built the
left half from the saber of his brother
Savage Opress become a nice way to honor
his bros memory definitely better than
like painting his face on your face but
the left half doesn't really look like
what we knew savages handle looked like
but behind Maul notice the throne of
Mandalore has been outlined in red
reflecting like the Maul death watched
this death marion's village and I just
love seeing this bo staff choreography
Sam Witwer returns to boy small as he
has in past Clone Wars episodes and in
solo but they also brought back Rey Park
to do motion capture for this lightsaber
combat so we're really gonna get the
best of all here on to the final clip
okay more battle shots here mall faces
off against the ahsoka helmeted 322nd
company clone troopers and it looks like
they're on a vinegar they're now
circling we know the duel between ahsoka
and mom must end in a kind of standoff
they both survived they both have
futures past this ahsoka later appears
and rebels Maul also shows them rebels
and rematch against ahsoka and the
season 2 finale twilight of the
apprentice awesome episode and later in
a rematch with obi-wan on Tatooine that
ends in malls death so an awesome moment
but between Clone Wars and rebels mom
also shows up in solo when he's leading
the crimson dawn so yeah future so I'm
predicting their fight will go all the
way to a dramatic climax and then get
interrupted when the clones suddenly
turn on them with oldest 66 which forces
both of them to flee Mandalore and this
conflict that we're seen on the vinegar
might be part of moles escape along with
last shot ahsoka waving their hand to
shut the doors on her and look at the
bottom of the frame there that's Rex
recovering on the floor I'm assuming
this shortly after he surgically removed
his brain chip he's post-op down there
after helping a souca escape her former
Clone Trooper friends were going crazy
under order 66 and now ahsoka is
protecting Rex and herself from the
other clone troopers they're trying to
kill him what are you most looking
forward to in this final season of the
Clone Wars comment down below with your
thoughts follow me Eddy gave us follow
the new rock stars on social media and
subscribe to new rock stars here new to
Bnei be sure to hit that notifications
button so you get all of our Star Wars
related videos thank you for watching
anime
[Music]